Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Weißt du,
Wer in Europa Rat sucht, findet diesen selten im Europarat, aber häufig auch nicht im Rat der EU und noch weniger im Europäischen Rat. Da macht sich ja Ratlosigkeit breit. Hitze auch nicht geraten, oder?
Nee.
Guter Rat ist teuer und den äh gibt's hier kostenlos bei Logbuch Netzpolitik, jetzt schon in der einhundertfünfunddreißigsten Iteration. Ja,
Hammer. Wir sind ja auch immer gut beraten, wenn äh unsere Hörer auf uns ähm wieder zurückkommen und ähm uns korrigieren beziehungsweise Hinweise äh geben auf mögliche Missstände in unserer Berichterstattung.
Missstände. Also es gab die letzte Folge wurde relativ viel kommentiert, aus irgendwelchen Gründen scheinen wir da.
Es könnte daran liegen, dass wir jetzt so äh offensiv auf das Feedback zugehen und es hier einbauen.
Ja, ich überlege ja, ob wir das überhaupt tun sollten,
Letzte Woche bei äh wann war das letzte Woche, war das, lief das, glaube ich, irgendwie im Fernsehen. Äh so eine Sendung, ähm wie heißt, kennst du Zapp? Ja. Kommt im Fernsehen, ZDF oder so was ist das, ne?
ID oder so. Ähm,
Da haben die haben sich für Trolle interessiert und da habe ich, habe ich über haben sie mich zu meinen Gedanken dazu gefragt, dass ja einige äh Redaktionen jetzt keine ähm keine Kommentare mehr haben oder so, dann.
Das Medienmagazin, NDR.
Können wir ja auch mal verlinken. Ja.
Also was Lukes gesagt?
Ja, aber das haben sie natürlich nicht gezeigt. Ich bin gerade noch in Verhandlungen mit denen, dass die äh das Gesamtinterview zeigen. Die haben so eine äh,
die haben eigentlich so eine Praxis, dass sie das gesamte Interview zeigen, was eigentlich ein ganz gutes Gespräch war und äh sie haben da dann nur einen bestimmten Themenbereich rausgenommen, nämlich eben die Redaktionen und,
sie so ein bisschen ignoriert haben, wann meine allgemeinen Erwägungen zu ähm zu träumen und so. Na ja, egal.
Tja, ist halt teuer, ne, die Sendeminute.
Minute ist teuer und davon kriege ich nicht viel.
Ja, okay, aber wir wir sind abgeschwiffen. Ähm.
Top Kandidat des Feedbacks waren unsere Ausführungen zum Thema Telemedizin,
ganze Zusammenhang mit den Äußerungen von Herrn Öttinger, wir erinnern uns, Taliban und so
und seinen Forderungen äh bezüglich einer Netzneutralität äh mit Einschränkungen, damit man ja auch noch äh bei zweihundertzwanzig auf der Autobahn Notoperation durchführen kann.
Wenn einer von rechts kommt.
Genau.
Das hätte der eigentlich noch direkt sagen können, ne, dass man quasi die Telemedizin ins Auto einbauen, dann sparst du nochmal sieben Minuten, bis die Rettungskräfte da sind. Das sollten wir dir mal empfehlen. Ähm.
Ich habe dir den Eindruck, hier müsste mal die Internetambulanz kommen und irgendwelche Leute irgendwo hinfahren.
Die Debatte war ja der der Kern meiner Aussage war ja, dass er mit Beispielen daher kommt, die nicht realistisch sind,
Und die nämlich heutzutage in dieser Form nicht stattfinden beziehungsweise die als Netzneutralitätsverletzungen heutzutage nicht stattfinden.
Und deswegen da auch kein Regulierungsbedarf besteht. Die Kommentare bestätigen das größtenteils,
Aber ähm weisen darauf hin, dass es tatsächlich Telemedizin gibt,
So kommentiert one not to be seen. Das mit der Telemedizin ist in Deutschland verbreiteter als man glauben mag, auch Echtzeitkritische Applikationen lalala. Ähm.
Wenn auch keine Remoteoperation. Ja, aber das ist ja schon der entscheidende Punkt, ja? Also ähm man man muss quasi unterscheiden, ist das Ferndiagnose oder Fern-OP, Fern-OP gibt's anscheinend nicht, aber Ferndiagnose. Das Beispiel, was er hier nennt, ist der verbreitete Klassiker, ist eine Schlaganfall akut Behandlung. Der Patient in der Wald- und Wiesenklinik wird
per Videokonferenz mit Pantils Zoom-Kamera neurologisch untersucht
und noch vor Ort behandelt. Von den Ärzten, die dort stehen. Wenn der Transport in die größere Klinik mit Neurologen zu lang dauert. Man hat ab Symptombeginn natürlich nur wenige Stunden Zeit für die gesamte Behandlung. Das gibt es in deutlich über einhundert deutschen Krankenhäusern,
Wenn die Videokonferenz hakt verzögert sich die Behandlung des Patienten, ja, um Sekunden, in dem Fall, schlimmsten Falls,
rutscht er aus dem Zeitfenster, in dem die Behandlung noch etwas bringt. Schlimmstmögliche Folge, äh permanente Behinderung und Tod. Ähm.
Nennt er sagt er auch, eine krassere Telemedizin-Applikation, die ernsthaft in Deutschland betrieben wird, kenne ich nicht. Okay, Ferndiagnostik, ne. Da kann man aber jetzt natürlich,
Könnte man jetzt sagen, okay, dann macht doch da mal ähm die Netzneutralität kaputt und,
richtet euch da mal über Holzspuren ein für diese Ferndiagnostik. Das Gegenteil ist aber der Fall. Das Interessante ist, schreibt er nämlich,
Überall läuft das, anders als du vermutest, übers Internet per VPN. Die Luxusvariante ist eine separate symmetrische DSL-Leitung in der Klinik für das Video. Gibt's aber natürlich nicht überall.
Mehr gibt man als Klinikum mit begrenzten IT-Budget dafür nicht aus. Branchen Standard ist ein VGA Video mit Monoaudio und circa fünfhundertzwölf Kilobit pro Sekunde.
Tja, das lief angeblich problemlos, da habe ich ja so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass das wirklich problemlos äh laufen kann, also vielleicht läuft's meistens.
Wenn es so schmalbandig ist, natürlich läuft das problemlos. Das kannst du ja wie Clemens immer so schön sagt, äh über nassen Schnürsenkel machen, diese Bandbreiten.
Naja, wenn halt nicht mal ein Router ausfällt, so.
Ja, wenn Route ausfällt, fällt, also du meinst jetzt im Klinikum oder.
Irgendwo auf dem Weg dahin, weil das ist ja das äh Ding. Ich meine, hier muss ja schon mal das VPN äh funktionieren. Es setzt ja immer voraus, dass dann auch alles irgendwie funktioniert.
Ja, aber sagen gestehen wir das mal zu, ähm was da jetzt geschildert wird, ähm,
sieht für mich nicht danach aus, dass da eine Netzneutralitätsverletzung schreiend notwendig wäre und vor allem, wenn es seit zweitausendacht machen, ohne dass sich irgendjemand ähm,
ernsthaft beschwert hat, ähm dann denke ich, besteht da jetzt gerade kein äh Bedarf. Abgesehen davon sei natürlich der Hinweis, äh erlaubt an dieser Stelle,
Aktuell gibt es keine Regulierung zur Netzneutralität in Deutschland oder in der EU,
und aktuell heißt das, die könnten das einfach machen. Das heißt,
Sie würden's machen, wenn es notwendig wäre. Sie sie möchten aber lieber äh Musikflatrates machen. Und ähm so, das scheint irgendwie insgesamt notwendiger zu sein, als äh diese Ferndiagnostik auf einen vernünftigen Stand zu bringen.
Was ja eigentlich angesprochen wurde, war ja die Sache mit den Operationen,
Ist ja so ein bisschen der Klassiker der Telemedizin ist. Hier wird in den Kommentaren auch nochmal drauf hingewiesen, dass das ja äh insofern auch schon äh problematisch ist,
ähm,
Ja, im Prinzip alles dann auch entsprechend medizintechnisch zertifiziert werden müsste, was Teil dieser Operation ist. Allein schon aus,
versicherungstechnischen Fragen, ja, wenn etwas schief geht, wer ist schuld? Und,
Naja, wenn man das halt irgendwie über das Internet macht, dann wäre ja im Prinzip jeder einzelne Router davon betroffen, der in dem Moment zum Einsatz kommt, was ja, wie wir wissen, im Internet,
irgendein Router sein kann, man weiß halt vorher nicht wirklich, was daran beteiligt ist und wie auch für diese Ferndiagnose kann ich eigentlich nur sagen.
Wenn das von der Politik und der Gesellschaft als einen,
Relevantes, wichtiges Instrument angesehen wird, dass sozusagen unsere medizinische Versorgung auch über solche digitalen
Wege mit unterstützt wird. Wofür ich, wo ich ja auch überhaupt gar nichts gegen habe. Ja, das ist ja eine eine gute Sache, wenn man sich einen Experten zuschalten lassen kann für eine Diagnose,
Wo man ansonsten unter Umständen einfach eine falsche Diagnose äh treffen würde oder vielleicht auch gar keine.
Und ähm aber wenn wenn das sozusagen angesehen wird als ein ein wichtiger Bestandteil, dann äh wäre natürlich eine Initiative, wie
hier ein Netzwerk, ein medizinisches Netzwerk in Deutschland, nennt das auch zwingend alle Krankenhäuser angeschlossen werden,
äh eine entsprechende administrative Hoheit beim Bund, bei irgendeiner Institution, die man zur Not dafür auch noch schaffen könnte, äh liegt,
Und äh die einfach die notwendigen Bandbreiten sicherstellen kann, die notwendige äh Verfügbarkeit sicherstellen kann
und vielleicht auch in einem bestimmten Maße eben auch äh eine Zertifizierung sicherstellen kann. Ich meine, Standleitungen sind ja nichts Neues. Das gibt es irgendwie seit den achtziger Jahren.
Und damals waren das halt im Wesentlichen noch äh ISDN, also vorher noch X fünfundzwanzig Leitung, später wurde dann halt sehr viel mit äh ISDN Standleitungen gemacht,
Ja, die jetzt nicht wirklich im Sinne von separate Leitungen sind, sondern eben ein dedizierter äh Teil des ISDN Netzwerks,
und damit ist man halt vollkommen entkoppelt von dem Internet und damit berührt es auch in keiner Hinsicht irgendeine Netzneutralitätsdebatte überhaupt und man hätte eben auch alle Vorteile, die das äh mit sich bringt.
Viel besseres Monitoring, man kann einfach genau sagen, wie gut funktioniert das, wenn's nicht gut funktioniert, kann man's zielgerichtet ausbauen und äh
Natürlich ist die Frage, wie das mit den Kosten ist, aber solche virtuellen Netze aufzubauen auf Basis der digitalen Infrastruktur, die wir heutzutage haben. Das ist absolut
machbar und möglich und das äh erfordert nur den politischen Willen, das durchzusetzen. Oder?
Ja, es scheint halt kein Bedarf zu bestehen, dass es sehe ich hier immer wieder.
Ja, offensichtlich ist es noch nicht so ein super Thema, aber es wird auf jeden Fall in der politischen Debatte hier um Netzneutralität verwendet und.
Genau, es wird als, es wird als unlauteres, genau, als unlauteres Argument hier benutzt an dieser Stelle, in meinen Augen. Da bleibe ich bei.
Aufgegriffen wurden dann unsere äh Hinweise und äh Debatten zum Thema äh Internet und Autos, das war ja dann so ein bisschen auch eins der Kernargumente von Herrn Oettinger, ja. Kommt einer von rechts.
Argument ist ein großes Wort.
Raumgreifend äh weist in den äh in den Kommentaren hin, dass es ja ähm,
Ja, wohl so sei, seine Aussage nach zumindest, dass solche Systeme ja kämen, ja? Ähm wenn eben auch nicht über das ähm Internet, also hier ist halt eigentlich eher von,
Sensor äh Networks die Rede natürlich, da hatten wir auch gesagt, glaube ich, dass Autos halt immer mehr sind, Soldaten haben und Diesel dann vielleicht auch mit der Infrastruktur oder anderen Autos
teilen wollen,
ja? Das ist so so diese generelle Idee, dass man eben Warnungen auch von anderen Autos bekommt, was weiß ich, da ist ein Stau, da ist was passiert, hier bremsen, alle et cetera solche Hinweise. Ja, aber auch das hat,
nichts direkt mit dem Internet zu tun.
Ja, also auch hier, dass ich hatte eigentlich gehofft, das hätte ich in der Sendung ausreichend betont. Er ähm Raumgreifend schreibt ja auch, hier einmal eine Ingenieursperspektive, die Idee, Sensordaten untereinander auszutauschen, ist nicht abwegig. Ähm,
Notfallbremsen und so weiter zu können dafür braucht man,
Noch nicht einmal selbstfahrender Auto sagte. Okay, Entschuldigung. Äh sonst hättest du Recht gehabt, lieber äh Raum greifend. Der der Punkt bleibt aber, es machte nur dann Sinn, wenn die das weit im Voraus wissen. Und wenn es nicht mehr zeitkritisch ist. Denn selbst wenn du äh
also die Autos müssten quasi wie so Flugzeuge, ne, die ganze Zeit sagen so, wenn wir so weiter fliegen in den nächsten zwanzig Minuten, dann knallen wir gegeneinander. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt den jetzt korrigieren, jetzt aufpassen oder sonstwas. Eine kurzfristige ähm,
Warnung, da fährt gerade einer über Rot oder so ist.
Stauende halt, ist so, würde ich sagen, ist so der Klassiker auf der Autobahn. Du hast halt irgendwie die Nachricht, dass da eben ein Stau ist und in dreihundert Metern ist das Stauende. Ja, worauf es immer das äh abgeleitet wird.
Fährt das Auto jetzt schon mal langsamer.
Da ist natürlich äh genug Möglichkeit zu warnen, das ist super, aber auch das würde niemals über das Internet laufen.
So ist das mit dem Internet. Wir können ja mal hier pingen und so. Also ja, wie dem auch sei. Also.
Kurze Ergänzung noch dazu und das wurde in den Kommentaren auch noch gemacht und das ist natürlich auch eine gewisse Träuberkeit hat, also sozusagen die Sicherheit von solchen Sensornetworks ist natürlich nochmal eine ganz andere Frage. Natürlich kann man sich ein System vorstellen, wo solche Autos alles äh
wunderbar untereinander miteinander funken und sich alle lieb haben. Aber wie wir aus dem Internet ja gelernt haben.
Hätte ich dann ein Fahrrad, was die ganze Zeit sagt. Das kommt von überall jemand, damit ich freie Fahrt habe. Ja klar.
Ja, so was, nicht wahr? Also äh einerseits halt so die die Betreuung oder im weiteren Sinne eben auch so das aktive herbeiführen von Unfällen durch,
Ausnutzung solcher Sensorsysteme und vor allem natürlich
nächste große Ding äh Ausnutzung einer etwaigen und absolut wahrscheinlichen Unsicherheit solcher Systeme, weil in dem Moment, wo etwas nicht konkret äh nicht korrekt implementiert ist oder einfach mal wieder unvorhergesehene Dinge äh passieren und Code falsch läuft und falsche Dinge macht. Das wirft eben
wie auch bei der Telemedizin wieder, so einen Rattenschwanz an äh Versicherungsfragen auf,
Ja, wer haftet dafür, wer ist jetzt irgendwie Schuld, wer muss hier dafür bezahlen? Das ist jetzt hier der Hersteller dieser Software, Suprotine, die jetzt an der Stelle einen Fehler gemacht hat und die durch null geteilt hat. Das, das sind einfach ungelöste Fragen. So oder so,
Mit der Netzneutralitätsdebatte, die wir jetzt führen, hat das alles herzlich wenig zu tun.
Genau, das ist alles äh der Bereich der Technik Philosophie. Ein wichtiger Bereich, der in der Regel halt äh mit dem Konkreten wenig äh zu.
Genau, es gab auch noch einen Hinweis von ähm Pascal Becker per E-Mail
ähm das Nokia auch tatsächlich an solchen Verkehrsverkehrswarnungssystemen arbeitet, die er halt über eine Infrastruktur gehen, aber auch an der Stelle nicht über eine Internetinfrastruktur, sondern über eine LTE-Infrastruktur.
Kann man jetzt sagen, LTE ist ja Internet, weil da ist ja sowieso alles äh IP-basiert, aber äh hier reden wir dann doch eher über Mobilfunk, Verbindungen,
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe mir nicht ganz genau durchgelesen, was sie da in ihren, wie heißt das, Liquid Application, da tatsächlich machen. Das Mobilfunknetze, den Verkehrsfluss monitoren, ist ja nichts Neues, also ein
ich weiß nicht, wie groß der Anteil ist, aber schon früh sind Mobilfunkdaten ähm verwendet worden. Ich glaube, zuerst bei Tom Tom,
um
die durchschnittlichen Geschwindigkeiten, die auf Straßen gefahren werden, zu analysieren. Das heißt, da hat man sich, glaube ich, ursprünglich mal mit Vodafone zusammengetan. Mittlerweile sind da wahrscheinlich alle in diesem Spiel dabei. Und hat halt einfach ähm
geschaut, natürlich anonymisiert, äh wie ähm mit Mobilfunkgeräten ausgestattete Autos, beziehungsweise.
Ausgestattet sind natürlich die Fahrer primär in diesen Autos, aber man kann halt, wenn man diesen, diesen Trafficanalyse macht
diese Bewegungsanalyse machst sehr schön sehen wie Autos durch Straßen fahren und kann natürlich dann eben in Abhängigkeit des Wochentages und der Uhrzeit für Straßen eine mittlere Geschwindigkeit
errechnen und damit natürlich dann auch feststellen, A ok, hier geht's jetzt langsamer voran, als normalerweise und das hat dann eben auch Rückwirkungen auf die
Navigationssysteme
äh wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist hier bei bei Nokia im Prinzip nichts anderes dann als die zweite und dritte Stufe davon in Planung, dass man das eben alles mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit macht.
Ja, aber sie sagen ja ähm, also sie haben jetzt nicht hier steht nicht äh Verkehrsunfallverhinderung drin. Sie sagen im Prinzip, okay, in LTE, ne, da ist die PlayStation,
Ja wieder im Prinzip klüger und fähiger als in den in den als in zwei G und drei G da sagen sie dann bauen wir,
Weil wir eine kluge Baystation nah am Kunden haben,
Ähm noch weitere Services ein, die sie auf der Funkschnittstelle sprechen soll.
Muss man mal schauen, wie fern sich daraus Standards überhaupt ableiten lassen oder dass nicht nur äh Insellösungen.
Genau und der, der, der Entscheidende, das entscheidende Argument ist hier, dass sie sagen, wir können das direkt von der Bastion machen und sparen uns den Umweg übers Internet,
Ja, das ist also wirklich explizit steht das hier so drin. Closed Proximity to the Mobile Customer anabelsign. In Time to content und so weiter. Tja, ja.
Hatten wir ja auch drüber geredet, die im äh Otto gespielt werden, über das Internet. Da meintest du, das wär ja alles nicht so wichtig.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt. Also da da habe ich gesagt, das Spiel kommt nicht aus dem Internet und es bleibt das Spiel läuft lokal
Spiel spricht mit einem anderen Spiel über ein Protokoll, um zu sagen, ich bin jetzt gerade hier lang gegangen und schieße in die Richtung oder so. Aber das Spiel wird selber jetzt nicht irgendwie da breitbandig hingestreamt.
Das gibt's aber auch schon.
Anderen darunter leiden.
Ja, das ist dumm.
Ja, das kann man, aber das gibt's auch.
Genau die, die dann das sind ja aber genau die, die das machen, sind ja diejenigen, die in Richtung Netzneutralitätsverletzungen arbeiten. Also diese ganze Argumentation ist so verquer, was ich meine ich auch in der letzten Sendung gesagt habe,
das, was er meint, was benachteiligt werden soll, sind diejenigen, die wie die irren Lobbyieren, dafür, dass sie bevorteiligt werden.
Aber das hat er noch nicht mitbekommen. So, dann, dann, da kannst du noch die Räte in Europa klarstellen,
möchtest oder wir wir verlinken einfach nur auf den Kommentar.
Ich habe versucht, das mal wieder äh einfach zu erklären. Also äh ich wurde darauf hingewiesen, dass ich natürlich den Unterschied zwischen dem Rat der Europäischen Union und dem Europäischen Rat nicht erläutert hatte, sondern nur den Unterschied zwischen dem dem
EU und äh dem Europarat, ja, also nochmal der Europarat ist ein keine EU-Institution
Und tatsächlich gibt es innerhalb der EU zwei ähnlich klingende äh Gruppen, die ich aber im Prinzip
in einen Topf geworfen habe, weil eigentlich nur der Rat der Europäischen Union wirklich relevant ist, der nimmt nämlich an diesem Gesetzgebungsprozess teil, gemeinsam mit der Kommission
und im Parlament und dann gibt es halt noch den äh jetzt keinen Fehler machen, den europäischen Rat und das ist wiederum,
also die Rater EU äh wird auch Ministerrat genannt, weil da sind sozusagen diese ganzen Minister der Regierungen tätig als Teil des Gesetzes,
prozesses. Der europäische Rat ist jetzt sozusagen nur die Regierungschefs, die sich zweimal im Jahr treffen.
Das ist nicht so eine dauerhafte äh Institution, sondern das ist mehr so ein Happening,
steht man dann halt rum, schön breit aufgestellt, lässt sich fotografieren und beschließt dann halt, was sozusagen der Rat der EU äh dann,
in Zukunft mal so alles äh antreiben soll und was auch von der Kommission hält et cetera PP. So ein bisschen das Gipfeltreffen,
Muss man auch alles nicht wissen. Wichtig sind vor allem, es gibt ein europäisches Parlament, ihr könnt euch da einbringen, da gibt's Abgeordnete, mit denen kann man reden und die bewirken in zunehmenden Maße immer mehr,
Die nehmen vor allem Einfluss auf die Kommission, dass der äh Rat noch mit einbezogen werden muss, also jeglicher Rat, der nicht der Europarat ist, das ist nochmal ein anderes Spiel.
Okay. Äh ich habe nix verstanden, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass alle alle Klarheit beseitigt ist an dieser Stelle.
Den Spitznamen geben. Das wäre wahrscheinlich ganz hilfreich.
Wir gründen einfach noch einen zur vollständigen Verwirrung des Feindes. Und wenn wir Glück haben, wenn wir Glück haben, können wir dann irgendwas beschließen und die anderen fressen das, weil sie selber nicht mehr checken.
Da müssen wir aber da müssen wir dann aber erstmal Rücksprache halten mit dem Podcast und dem Rat der europäischen Podcaster.
Der Europäische Rat hat beschlossen.
Euro-Rad.
Eurorat, der Rat, der, der, der Europäischen Ratio. Ja, genau. Keine Ahnung, also okay.
Verband der europäischen Räte.
Der Verband, der europäische Dachverband.
Genau, die europäische Retterebung.
Das machen wir. Okay, ab jetzt nur noch äh nicht öffentlich äh in die Planungsphase übergehen. So, dann müssen wir uns jetzt mal der Vorratsdatenspeicherung widmen.
Widmen. Denn andere tun das ja auch.
Hm, andere tun das auch. Es ging irgendwie damit los, dass dann die Meldung kam, ja, Sigmar Gabriel will jetzt äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ich fand das, ich fand das so lustig, weil du das letzte Mal ja wirklich noch ausführlich dargelegt hast, wie ja immer wieder diese Debatte hochgehalten wird und immer wieder am Kochen gehalten wird, damit man irgendwie das Gefühl hat. Oder haben wir das? Da haben wir doch letztes Mal drüber gesprochen oder habe ich das nur gelesen jetzt,
weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich habe so eine Debatte auf jeden Fall jetzt noch im Kopf. Ja, dass das sozusagen das Wichtig sei, dass ja immer wieder darüber geredet wird, damit man später auch sagen kann, man hätte ja darüber geredet, man hätte es ja schon immer auch gefordert. Ja, das so so ein bisschen eine der Erklärungen, warum diese VDS-Debatte einfach nicht enden will.
Und so endet sie eben wiederum nicht und jetzt kommt halt auch so ein bisschen der Dauerbrenner in dieser äh Debatte der Dauer umstürzt Herr äh,
Gabriel.
Das ist schon das ist schon beachtlich, der Gabriel, das ist schon beachtlich. Hast du das gelesen? Der ist jetzt äh Ehrenmitglied der CDU geworden.
Das war aber jetzt ein.
Gabriel setzt sich immer wieder für christliche
demokratische Politik ein und stärkt die Union nachhaltig erklärte Merkel. Dabei lobte sie besonders die Vielseitigkeit, mit der sich der Geehrte sowohl für Wirtschaftsliberale Themen
als auch erzkonservative Interessen einsetze. Er kämpft unermüdlich für das Freihandelsabkommen TTIP, er beglückt Privatinvestoren, indem er öffentlich private Partner für öffentlich-private Partnerschaften wirbt,
jetzt sorgt er sogar noch dafür, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kommt. Dafür wollen wir uns endlich erkenntlich zeigen. Danach gab's ja auch noch irgendwie die Meldung, dass er vor kurzem die
die nächste Wahl schon mal präventiv als äh verloren äh.
Innen nimmt.
Hinnimmt. Also unglaublich.
Und,
Er trat dann irgendwie auf, ja, das war ja früher alles ganz, ganz, äh, ganz, ganz falsch und so, die die Vorratsdatenspeicherung war früher schlimm. Und deswegen wird er jetzt erklären, wie die Vorratsstaatenspeicherung gut wird,
Und ähm
Ich glaube, die Einschränkung, die er dann so nennt, ist ähm oder die ja der Süddeutschen sagte, ich bin seit langem für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung unter sehr engen Bedingungen. Richtervorbehalt
relativ kurze Speicherfristen und Einsatz nur bei besonders schweren Straftaten.
All das war im Gesetz von CDU, CSU und FDP nicht enthalten. Deshalb war es auch verfassungswidrig. Gibt's eine schöne Aufstellung der der TAZ, also es du kannst dir sowas nur noch durchlesen und mit dem Kopf schütteln.
Sagt, naja, äh also nochmal, Zitat Gabriel in der Süddeutschen Zeitung. All das war im alten Gesetz von CDU, CSU und FDP nicht enthalten.
Tatsache ist,
Das Gesetz sofort sagten Speicherung wurde zweitausendacht von der Großen Koalition aus Union und SPD beschlossen federführend war SPD Justizministerin Brigitte Zypries.
Danke Herr Gabriel, dass sie also hm? So viel, so viel dazu,
das Gesetz hatte damals auch schon einen Richtervorbehalt,
Das war nicht der Grund, warum es gescheitert ist. Zitat Gabriel,
Richtervorbehalt, relativ kurzes Speicherfristen, Einsatz nur bei besonders schweren Straftaten. All das war im alten Gesetz lala nicht enthalten. Deshalb war es auch verfassungswidrig. Ist nicht richtig. Ähm,
Das Gesetz war nicht verfassungswidrig wegen der Speicherfristen oder wegen eines fehlenden Richter Vorbehalts, denn den hatte es und einsatz bei besonders schweren Straftaten war ebenso vorgesehen.
Ja.
Wir sollten ihm irgendwie eine Rechnung schicken.
Dann, was er auch immer wieder macht, das hatte schon vor vor wirklich vor langer Zeit ähm,
Netzpolitik Org auch ähm korrekt bemängelt, dass er sagte, ähm.
Dass er, dass er sagt, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Norwegen hätte zu einer schnelleren Aufdeckung von Straftaten geführt,
Zum Beispiel bei dem Attentat von Herrn Anders Breiwig. Das waren ja, das waren ja äh siebenundsiebzig äh Menschen, die der Mann getötet hat. Ähm.
Und zwar auf dieser, auf dieser Insel Utuja. Da war ja dann, glaube ich, auch noch Sozialdemokratische Kind, eine sozialdemokratische,
Organisation. Das ist natürlich ein Thema, was den was den äh Gabriel interessiert. Da konzentriert er sich dann auch mehr auf das Thema, als auf die Fakten.
Und.
Der wurde ja von einer Antiterroreinheit noch auf festgenommen, der. Da gab's ja noch gar nicht die Möglichkeit, äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh zu nutzen, denn die gab es,
Damals wie heute nicht in Norwegen. Also.
Der Mann ist auf einer auf einer Kampagne, auf einer auf einer Reise für dieses Thema zu werben,
Der tritt sich damit ein riesen Ärger mit allen möglichen Leuten ein,
Selbst die Netzwirtschaft hier, also die Verbände wie Eco oder so, sind ähm laut dagegen,
Und am schönsten finde ich ja die Reaktion von D vierundsechzig,
D vierundsechzig. Wir hatten das immer mal wieder erwähnt, ist der die SPD nahe ähm netzpolitische Vereinigung, ja?
Ja, Aktionsgruppe, wie auch.
Aktionsgruppe und die hatten den Gabriel, glaube ich, sogar noch auf ihrem auf ihrem Neujahrsempfang am fünfundzwanzigsten Februar
Lange Rede von SPD Chef Sigmar Gabriel. Äh Lars Klingbeil und äh Nico Lümmer, der der Co-Vorsitzende und ich glaube Mitgründer ist ähm.
Und irgendwie drei Wochen später tritt er den halt in den Rücken,
ist auf einmal für die, für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ja? Die machen da irgendwie ihre Werbeveranstaltung für den, ne? Es, Netzpolitik in der SPD und jetzt tritt er denen dermaßen ins Kreuz.
Entsprechend ist der Nico Lummer auch etwas ungehalten,
Die haben also jetzt erstmal natürlich Pressemitteilung rausgegeben in der, denke ich, die zentrale Aussage sehr schön zusammengefasst ist, dass sie sagen, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist nicht nur vollkommen wirkungslos.
Wenn es um die Verhinderung von Verbrechen geht, die Regierung setzt damit auch ein deutliches Zeichen für Überwachung und gegen Freiheitsrechte,
Ja, also was muss der.
Wie wie ernst muss dieser Gabriel seine Ehrenmitgliedschaft in der CDU nehmen, dass er jetzt so einen Schaden auf die Partei zieht, ja? Und,
Der schlimmste, den schlimmsten Schaden nimmt ja dann unser Freund Heiko Maas auf sich, den ich immer so oft erwähne, weil der Justizminister ist und ähm über den,
Wo ich schon fast ein schlechtes Gewissen habe, weil der Mann ja eigentlich in Ordnung war.
Bisher hat er sich auf jeden Fall halbwegs klug geäußert.
Bisher hat er sich, hat er sich besonnen gezeigt und hat mein genießt als eines der wenigen Regierungsmitglieder eigentlich mein Vertrauen. Mir ist das nachher irgendwie bewusst geworden, dass ich eurem CCC Jahresrückblick habe ich den öfter herausgestellt, weil er mal was,
mal,
Blödes gesagt hat, neben vielen klugen Dingen vorher, wo er nix gesagt hat oder wo er einfach nichts gemacht hat, was ja auch in der Regel klüger ist. Ähm,
aber,
so vermeldet ist Heise vor drei Tagen. Bereits zum Parteikonvent der SPD am zwanzigsten Juni zweitausendfünfzehn soll eine Leitlinie der Sozialdemokraten zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorliegen,
ähm und,
der Heiko Maas möchte in in der ersten Fassung des Entwurfs bereits die Vorgaben des Europäischen Gerichtshofs und des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
berücksichtigen. Wie gesagt, unter Befürwortern der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist das natürlich der einzig gangbare und der sinnvolle Weg. Ähm die.
Die Urteile, in denen das Mittel als verfassungswidrig eingestuft wird, als Anleitung zu nehmen, um einen Gesetzesentwurf zu schreiben, der dann nicht mehr kassiert wird von von den entsprechenden Gerichten.
Ja, ich verlinke hiermit ähm dann mal in den aber auf den Artikel von Spiegel Online, die haben das nämlich tatsächlich zuerst gemeldet.
Das stimmt. Ja, haben sie.
Ja, mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt. Also, man kann sich ganz gut vorstellen, dass äh der Herr Maas da innerhalb der Koalition ganz ordentlich unter Druck ist, immer irgendwie was so machen und,
Mal sagen, da warten wir mal lieber mal ab, was das für Leitlinien sind, die er da vorliegt, bevor wir da jetzt abschließend drüber urteilen. Aber die Debatte reist natürlich nicht ab.
Wie gesagt, Nico Lümmer sollte man in der in diesem Zusammenhang echt mal im Auge behalten. Der ist ja seit Kurzem auch äh Kolumnist bei Bild DE. Ähm was.
Ähm was was uns jetzt auch ein Bild-Link äh sozusagen hier.
Was uns einen Bild-Link einträgt hier. Ähm das fand ich natürlich sehr also das.
Dafür da können wir auch nochmal eine Rechnung rausschicken eigentlich.
Stimmt, dürfen wir die überhaupt auf die linken?
Vorsichtshalber, schreib mal da Bildlink hin und nimm nicht übernimm nicht den Titel, nicht dass wir nachher irgendwie auf die Fresse bekommen von denen. Apropos, ob.
Ach so, du meinst wegen äh, wissen schon.
Apropos auf die Fresse bekommen. Nico Lummer titelt in seiner Netzkolumne bei Bild DE. Die SPD will einfach Kloppe bekommen.
Ja, einer musste es tun. Ähm ich bin ganz froh, dass Nico Lummer da seinen seinen guten Ruf opfert und um als Bildkolumnist da ähm.
Auch zu besetzen und ähm das für für deren Leserschaft zu tun, das ist ähm ein, denke ich, insgesamt ein von der,
ein wichtiger Einsatz, den er bringt. Man kann da natürlich auch wieder irgendwie drauf rumran, für Bild schreiben oder so. Aber ähm ich finde das insgesamt schon ganz gut, dass dass wir da einen Nikolumma haben, der insgesamt das Herz nämlich am rechten Fleck hat, bevor,
es irgendwie ein ein Jan Fleischhauer-Äquivalent in der Netzpolitik gegeben hätte, der dann dort.
Ja, na gut, da gibt's dann immer noch genug Leute, die in der Bild-Zeitung schreiben, die das, glaube ich, auch gerne in die andere Richtung dann.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber wie gesagt, die Alternative wäre, es gibt noch nicht einmal eine Stimme, die in der Regel sich sehr, äh, zumindest die richtigen Positionen vertritt.
Ähm und deswegen finde ich das ganz gut, dass er das macht.
Ja, wir verlinken trotzdem mal äh mit vollem Titel da drauf und wenn wir dann eine Rechnung kriegen, dann schicken wir die an Nico weiter.
Ja. Ja okay, so machen wir das. Ich weiß nicht, ob er deine Rechnung kriegt oder sofort. Ja, aber Rechnung, ne? Lieze Lizenzangebot kriegen wir. Wir kriegen ein Lizenzangebot, das wir nicht ablehnen können. So, so.
Wir freuen uns drauf. Ja, das ist nicht so, dass jetzt Logbuch Netzpolitik keine keine Öffentlichkeit erreichen würde, aber die zusätzlichen zusätzliche Aufmerksamkeit nehmen wir dann gerne mit.
Ja. Gut, dann gab's jetzt eine eine Meldung, da gehe ich mal kurz noch in die Vorgeschichte.
Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik ist ja ein ein Amt, das dem,
Innenministerium untersteht, was ein Kritikpunkt ist, den wir als Chaos-Computerclub schon öfter angeführt haben. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Idee von uns stammt, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ähm denn es gibt auch andere, die,
die diese Kritik anbringen und daraus die Forderung ableiten, dass Bundesamt für sich halt in der Informationstechnik möge doch bitte,
als eigenständige, unabhängige Behörde aufgestellt werden, so wie es mit der Datenschutzbeauftragten jetzt,
kürzlich geschehen ist und sich dann auch herausgestellt hat, dass das nicht besonders gefährlich wurde der Regierung. Diese Frau eigenständig operieren zu lassen, ähm Scherz beiseite.
Warte mal, habe ich da was nicht mitbekommen? Das die Datenschutzbeauftragte untersteht nicht mehr dem Innenminister.
Wird und haben wir vor vielen, vielen Folgen drüber gesprochen, ja. Ähm.
Blamiert.
Und jetzt die, die Ratio war ja immer, dass die, dass das Bundesamt für sich halt in der Informationstechnik,
Als Aufgabe hat den Bürgern zu sichereren Informationstechnischen Systemen zu verhelfen, während das äh Bundesinnenministerium ein,
strenges Interesse hat, die Bürger daran zu hindern, derartige Systeme wirklich aufzubauen, zumindest derartige Systeme auf die dann das Bundesinnenministerium und seine,
Ermittlungsbehörden, wie die Deutschen Geheimdienste, Bundes- und Landespolizeien, nicht mehr zugreifen können. Das heißt, es gibt,
Zentralen Interessenkonflikt zwischen dem dem BSi und seiner übergeordneten Behörde,
Und der der äußerte sich ja zum Beispiel in so Sachen wie der Spezifikation von D Mail, wo dann,
tief, ein, eine Architektur promotet wurde, die eine Abhörschnittstelle beinhaltet. Ähm.
Wo immer was werden noch schöne Beispiele, ja. Wie dem auch sei. Ein wunderschönes Beispiel, was wir jetzt auch noch haben, ist, dass nämlich das BSI bei der,
Programmierung eines Staatstrojaners,
mitgeholfen hat. Zwar muss man da schon sehr zynisch sein, um zu erkennen, dass das BSI da noch äh den Bürgern dieses Landes einen Gefallen tut,
Denn was das BSI getan hat, ist es hat für die den Remote-Zugriff,
den ähm ja dann der Start auf den Computer des Opfers hat.
Oder der Zielperson hat, mit einer äh wirksamen Verschlüsselung versieht.
Und diese die Verschlüsselung dieser Fernkommunikation, die hat das BSI.
Ähm empfohlen und ähm implementiert.
Hm. Das weiß man jetzt weswegen?
Das hat wurde sind interne Dokumente, die Netzpolitik orggelegt wurden, während,
vor kurzem das BSI noch in einer Pressemitteilung sagte, weder das BSI noch seine Empfehlungen und Produkte stehen in Verbindung mit Onlinedurchsuchungen.
Das BSI beschäftigt sich mit Trojanern und deren Vorgehensweise ausschließlich mit dem Ziel, solche Angriffe abzuwehren. Das ist eben nicht wahr. Das ist nicht wahr. Denn sie haben,
Wie gesagt, Andre ist im Besitz von Dokumenten, in denen das BSI quasi,
Abschluss des Projektes Fernzugriffsstelle auf Staatstrojaner.
Quasi den Abschluss bestätigt. Und wie man schön sieht, dass BSI arbeitet hier
mal wieder gegen die Sicherheit der Bürger und Bürgerinnen. Man müsste, wie gesagt, man könnte jetzt sehr zynisch sagen, nein, nein, sie arbeiten ja für die Sicherheit, weil sie ja dafür gesorgt haben, dass der
Staatstrojaner nicht abgehört werden kann, das heißt ähm der Staat hört dich ab, aber du bist natürlich dann noch vor weiteren Kriminellen geschützt, die dich abhören könnten,
Ähm aber klar, diese diese Aktivität der Beteiligung an einem.
Ermittlungswerkzeug, das in Deutschland ja auch nach aktueller Rechtslage nicht legal ist,
das kannst du ja ernsthaft, kannst ja nicht ernsthaft vertreten als Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Insofern,
Dem Laden ist einfach grundsätzlich nicht zu trauen, wenn er äh so etwas tut. Und da kann der Laden selber ja noch nichts mal was für. Ähm sie sind ja weisungsgebunden, wenn etwas vom Innenministerium kommt.
Da sieht man einmal, ähm wie sich wie sich so etwas dann auswirkt. Finde ich ähm schon ziemlich übel.
Unsicherheit in der Informationstechnik,
Oh Mann. Ja, mehr gibt's da nicht zu sagen, oder?
Nee, wir, also das da gibt's nicht viel zu sagen. Das das muss man sich nur merken, wenn die das nächste Mal irgendwo in irgendein Thema sich einmischen wollen, ne? Ich meine, reden wir übers äh IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Da haben wir,
Das BSI in einer zentralen Rolle, ne? Da wollen sie ja zum Beispiel, möchte das BSI eben über Angriffe ähm,
in der Industrie informiert werden, gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus, dass diese Angriffe schwachstellen betreffen.
Dann ergibt sich hier ein Kanal, wie äh die Ausnutzung von Schwachstellen oder die Existenz von Schwachstellen dem BSI mitgeteilt werden,
Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie geht das BSI mit diesem Wissen um? Mein,
Bauen sie das dann in ihre Trojaner ein? Oder sorgen sie dafür, dass äh dass die Bürger vor dieser Schwachstelle,
äh gewarnt und geschützt werden. Klammer auf, ähm Angriffe auf Unternehmen, äh aber,
gehen selten über über unbekannte Schwachstellen. Ähm das geht,
ganz anders, wie man wie man oder viel einfacher als sich jetzt ein ein teures äh Zero-Date zu kaufen um Unternehmen zu hacken, aber dazu sage ich dann später nochmal was, wenn ich mich ausführlich mit dem IT-Sicherheits,
Sicherheitsgesetz beschäftige, das werde ich so in den nächsten äh Wochen tun.
Okay. So, dann gibt's auch noch äh Bewegung in der Wirtschaft. Ja.
In der Wirtschaft? Ich glaube, du bist du hast ein ein Thema übersprungen, aber es ist nicht schlimm.
Wieso?
Es gibt ein Thema in es gibt äh Bewegung in der Beschwerde von Privacy International und dem Chaos Computerclub vor dem britischen Investory Power Stripional,
Wir erinnern uns, das ist dieses, das ist das geheim Gericht der,
dass die Briten über ihre Geheimdienste gelegt haben. Oder ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Geheimgericht ist, aber das ist quasi das, das nicht öffentlich tagende ähm Gericht,
und das eben dafür zuständig ist, die Rechtmäßigkeit der Aktivitäten des GCHQ zu zu regeln. Und das Schöne ist,
In dem Dokument, was der CCC und Privace International jetzt veröffentlicht haben, du guckst so komisch.
Ja, weil ich gerade mit deinen Notizen nicht mehr klarkomme, irgendwie steht hier was mit SAP und du bist jetzt irgendwie.
Genau, aber schau mal, fettgedruckt ist immer, dass das die Überschrift.
Ja, ich weiß.
So und da siehst du in dem Pad.
Ähm ah ja okay, jetzt bin ich auf.
Ähm okay. Jetzt hast du das Thema vorweggenommen, so also du hast jetzt gespoilert. Du hast jetzt echt mal gespoilert, Tim.
Sorry. Ja, tut mir leid.
Okay, also echt nicht in Ordnung.
Dafür trage ich deine ganzen schlechten Witze mit.
Wieso schlecht? Ey, jetzt geht's aber los hier. Also.
Geht's aber nicht. Ich decke dich.
In dieser, in diesem in diesem Dokument ist es so, dass der, dass das,
IPT sagt, die Hacking-Aktivitäten, die offensiven Angriffsaktivitäten des GCAQ in den letzten zehn Jahren, zum Beispiel, als sie äh den belgischen äh Carrier und Provider ähm,
gehackt haben.
Politik berichtete.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete, waren illegal. Unrechtmäßig.
Die Regeln, unter denen das Hacking vollzogen wurde, waren, aber bisher nicht öffentlich. Da sie nun aber bekannt gegeben sind, ist es alles ab jetzt legal.
Argumentation. Ah.
So die Argumentation. Also, es war illegal, aber es wusste ja auch keiner.
Und jetzt wissen's ja alle.
Und deswegen ist es jetzt egal, weil's jetzt alle wissen.
Ist es jetzt legal.
Oder wie?
So ungefähr. Ich weiß nicht, wie wie man das verargumentieren kann. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das verargumentieren kann.
Also was haben sie denn jetzt sozusagen beschlossen? Also ist das jetzt ein neues Gesetz oder ist das so sozusagen nur eine eine Feststellung oder äh.
Das ist eine Feststellung für die für dieses Verfahren. So ist die Argumentation.
Seine Argumentation der Regierung oder dieses Gerichts oder sozusagen eine juristische Feststellung, dass dass es jetzt legal sei, obwohl's eigentlich nicht legal ist.
Genau, es war nicht legal, aber ab jetzt ist das in Ordnung, jetzt wissen's ja alle.
Mhm.
So ist, ich kann da jetzt nicht, ich kann das jetzt nicht weiter verteidigen.
Ja. Na gut, aber das ist jetzt sozusagen im Rahmen also das ist jetzt sozusagen die Bewertung des, des, dieses IPT, ja?
Ja, na gut, das für Geheimgerichte haben, dann ist immer alles total klar. Ich kann, ehrlich gesagt, nicht so ganz folgen, aber das ist, das ist jetzt sozusagen auch der, der erwartete Effekt, den du hier.
Ja, was soll ich dazu noch sagen? Ich war.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, es ist das nicht. Ich bin einfach nur ein bisschen verwirrt.
So ist das jetzt. Hast du verstanden? So. Nimmst du jetzt so zur Kenntnis und dann kann man zum nächsten Thema.
Okay.
Was willst du dazu noch sagen? Also die haben damit jetzt sich selber die weltweiten Hacking äh Befugnisse gegeben. Wir dürfen das alles machen. Es ist ja jetzt auch öffentlich.
Okay. Ignoranz ist.
Ja, so läuft das jetzt halt.
Okay, verstehe.
Verwunderlich gewesen, wenn sie, wenn sie da zu irgendeinem anderen Ergebnis gekommen.
Ja, schon. So, jetzt schalten wir mal die Börse.
Jetzt schalten wir an die Börse, zum zum äh zu der Firma SAP. Ähm SAP,
ist den meisten bekannt als ein als ein IT-Unternehmen, das ähm Daten, Banken,
Systeme für Unternehmen baut, in denen sich ihre Geschäftsprozesse abbilden lassen. Ich.
Ja, man könnte auch sagen, sie sind definitiv so das Betriebssystem des des gehobenen Mittelstandes und auch äh vor allem größerer Konzerne, gibt,
glaube ich, keinen Konzern. Richtig gut kenne ich mich da nicht aus, aber äh es wird
einfach keinen Konzern, keine kein Unternehmen ab einer bestimmten äh Größe äh geben, die nicht in irgendeiner Form mit SAP Software arbeiten, schlicht und ergreifend, weil sie eben auch mit allen anderen zusammenarbeiten müssen, die auch SAP einsetzen und dort werden halt diese gesamten Wirtschaftsprozesse
Ähm ja, digital abgebildet und haben sich sozusagen auch als quasi Standard durchgesetzt. Das geht ja schon lange
so äh gibt's ja auch Hehrschaden von.
Wann war das? In den neunziger Jahren oder wann als oder in neunziger Jahren, wo alle Unternehmen dann umgestellt haben, ich kenne das noch. Dann haben die da musste jetzt alles SAP, dann haben die einmal alles das Groß den großen Umschwung gemacht und jetzt ist das eben alles in SAP.
Genau so SAP Berater wurde auf einmal so ein so ein Berufsbild wie Schreinermeister, das das war dann einfach so. Das das hat,
vielen Leuten da äh durchaus eine Beschäftigung äh gegeben, die Leute waren auch sehr gut bezahlt. Ich kenne also einige Leute, die so auch als Quereinsteiger ohne nennenswerte Computerkenntnisse
da äh hineingeraten sind und sich halt einfach diese Systeme äh ermächtigt haben und äh ja, ein gutes Leben halten.
Genau und jetzt hat die ähm jetzt hat diese dieses Unternehmen natürlich über seine Jahre
die Datenbanken in die Unternehmen verkauft und sind so ein bisschen Experte für für Datenbanken geworden, das war halt ihr, das ist das, was sie verkaufen, Datenbanken,
Und wenn man dann irgendwann mal so weltweit der der Standard und Marktführer für Enterprise-Datenbanken ist, dann äh muss man sich natürlich auch überlegen, in welche Richtung man jetzt noch weiter ähm wachsen möchte und wie man,
auch die Qualität seines Produktes regelmäßig weiter erhöhen kann. Und was jetzt vor einigen Wochen schon,
dann im welches wie heißt die Sendung wieder?
MDR Fakt, MDR Fakt hat das äh gesendet. Ähm das Ergebnis einer Recherche, wie nämlich SAP. Seit einigen Jahren,
sehr aktiv in den Geheimdienstmarkt geht. Spezifisch in den ähm NSA und BND Markt. Auch darüber hatten wir schon berichtet, dass SAP sich nämlich rühmt mit der Datenbank Hanau
ein das schnellste Datenbanksystem,
überhaupt zu haben, insbesondere für eben diese gesamten geheimdienstlichen Sammlungen. Denn.
Die Massenüberwachung war technisch nie das Problem. Du konntest immer alles auf den einen oder auf den anderen Weg abhören, was den Menschen zur Verfügung stand. Das Problem war immer, das alles,
sinnvoll zu speichern,
zu organisieren und durchsuchbar zu machen. Das war die, das ist und bleibt die Herausforderung der Massenüberwachung,
und genau dieser Herausforderungen können sich natürlich nur Unternehmen mit besonderen,
Besonderer Expertise in Datenbankbaustellen,
und selbstverständlich ist SAP da eines der Unternehmen, was an dieser Stelle einen Markt sieht, in dem sie gerne sich hinein entwickeln wollen, insbesondere in den USA,
Und da haben sie in den letzten Jahren
verschiedene Unternehmen gekauft, einmal Inside, die eine optimierte Suche für personenbezogene Daten gebaut haben, ähm dann
Cybese, ein Datenbankhersteller, dessen Hauptkunde die NSA ist. Außerdem haben sie äh zusammen Verträge über die Zusammenarbeit mit
und Attency äh geschlossen auch äh Zulieferer der der NSA.
Und haben daran gearbeitet, mit einer eigenen Firmengründung,
sich auch die die gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen zu erfüllen, um Zulieferer der NSA zu werden, denn ganz so schnell kaufen die ähm kaufen die Amerikaner eben nicht bei einem,
bei einem Zulieferer aus einem anderen Land und deswegen gibt es also eine eigenes Unternehmen,
in den USA, dass äh aus diesen aufgekauften Firmen äh besteht, wo dann alle Mitarbeiter die entsprechenden Security Clearences haben, um aktiv eben an dem äh schönen, großen Markt, der
NSA zu partizipieren.
Und dazu wurde ich dann auch mal äh von von Fakt befragt, habe da auch ein bisschen was zu gesagt und ähm jetzt,
Ist SAP vor zur Cebit mit einer Pressemitteilung an die,
Andi Welt getreten, wo sie sagen unsere Produkte haben keine Hintertüren für die NSA,
Die Behauptung ist falsch. Die Behauptung hat nur nie jemand aufgestellt. Was was ganz interessant,
Natürlich ähm.
Na hier ist aber die Rede davon, dass es Berichte gäbe.
Dass dem diese Behauptung hat keiner ähm aufgestellt.
Gerüchte klar, völlig in Ordnung. Äh es ist ja auch also natürlich hat das verschiedene.
Stellen sich verschiedene Fragen, wenn so ein Unternehmen aktiv für Geheimdienste arbeitet. Da hast du, da stellen sich einfach bestimmte Fragen. Zum Beispiel.
Dann so also.
Stellen wir uns mal vor, SAP baut da jetzt ein Produkt für die NSA, irgendwie so eine Hahner Datenbank, die irgendwie besonders schnell ist,
Stellen wir uns mal vor, die NSA würde jetzt sagen, ah, das ist aber schon sehr, sehr gut, was ihr da baut,
damit wir das abkaufen, müsst ihr aber bitte hier unterschreiben, dass das, was ihr an andere verkauft, mindestens Faktor zehn oder fünfzehn langsamer ist. Stellen wir uns mal.
Sowas vor. Völlig hypothetisch jetzt. Wer aber natürlich aus aus Sicht der NSA eine sinnvolle äh Restriktion, um diesen um diesen Handel eben stattfinden lassen zu können.
Das Problem ist ja für die NSA, dass dass SAP eben auch an andere Länder verkaufen könnte. Unabhängig davon kriegt die kriegt SAP natürlich von,
Den Geheimdiensten eine dermaßene Herausforderung an Daten, die es zu strukturieren und zu speichern und ähm,
Zur analysieren gilt, dass der Enterprise Markt danach für sie,
Ein lächerlicher Klack sein wird für die nächsten Jahrzehnte. Wenn du sagst, okay, wir können.
Personenbezogene Daten und Kommunikation im Internet vollständig erfassen,
und sinnvoll durchsuchbar in unserer Datenbank machen, dann ist halt so ein kleiner DAX-Konzern mit seinen paar Verkaufsprozessen oder so. Ist ja dann halt nur noch ein Witz für deine, für deine Anlage.
Das heißt, du entwickelst da. Du lernst da natürlich ähm Dinge, die oder du entwickelst da nochmal eine Expertise, die SAP wahrscheinlich ohnehin schon in im besonderem Ausmaß hat. Aber es gibt halt für die nur eine eine Herausforderung, an der sie sich,
ähm,
An der sie sich stellen können und das wäre eben für die das eben für große Geheimdienste zu arbeiten. Auf der anderen Seite steht natürlich die Herausforderung, wenn andere Unternehmen das machen, dann werden aus den relativ schnell ähm ernstnehmende Konkurrenten für SAP.
Und das scheint eben das Management bei SAP auch verstanden zu haben und hat eben seit Jahren,
Darauf hingearbeitet in in diesen Markt ähm vorzudringen. Und in diesen Markt zu arbeiten,
Gleichzeitig stellen sie sich sind sie sich natürlich nicht zu schade äh äh sich in Deutschland hinzustellen und zu sagen yay wir sind deutsch äh kauft bei uns und nicht äh,
Seid gewarnt vor der US-Cloud, kauft lieber äh SAP-Infrastruktur äh made in Germany oder so, ne? Das äh da sind sie natürlich nicht, sind sie nicht zu schade für.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sehr in Germany SAP eigentlich noch ist. Also es gibt natürlich hier nach wie vor die äh Zentrale.
Wo sind die nochmal in wie heißt die Stadtnummer? Das ist doch so eine SAP hat ja quasi seine eigene Stadt.
Ja, Hoffenheim wahrscheinlich, oder bei Hoffenheim zumindest da rund um den äh Fußballverein herum, Stuttgart. Ich glaube, wir sind in Stuttgart, ne?
Ja, die die haben die gehört ja nicht, auch der Verein.
Ja, das ist ja der ehemalige Chef der Gründer vom ähm von SAP, aber mittlerweile, wie ich äh grade hier beim Nachklicken festgestellt habe, wird ja seit vier Jahren.
Walldorf ist übrigens die Stadt.
Genau richtig das war's. Das ist da die Gegend. Und ähm äh der Vorstandssprecher von SAP ist einer US-Amerikaner seit vier Jahren fünf.
Birmacd Dörmit.
Genau. Ja. Tja. Und jetzt? Also,
Jetzt wollen das alle haben, also weil jetzt irgendwie, also wenn ich da nochmal zusammenfassen darf,
Also dieses taugt wohl was, so eine In-Melmorie-Datenbank, die ist sehr schnell, also die kann irgendwie braucht wahrscheinlich Systeme, die auch sehr viel Speicher haben,
Rechner mit viel Ramm oder SSD zwischen Speicher und Cash und keine Ahnung. Und ist ja, sagen wir mal durchaus so eine äh angemessene
Entwicklung in der Datenbanktechnik, dass man halt sagt, wir müssen die Latenzen äh vermeiden. Früher ging's ja dadrum, die Sachen überhaupt erstmal zu speichern. Da ging's darum, dass große Datenmengen abzulegen.
Heutzutage geht's eher dadrum, diese Daten auch möglichst schnell verfügbar zu machen, das war schon bei Google von Anfang an ein Thema, natürlich,
ne, für die Suche und äh in zunehmenden Maße ist es natürlich auch ein Thema für die Echtzeitanalyse von von Daten.
Mhm.
Also die Sache ist, wenn du mit so einer Riesenmenge an Daten zu tun hast, dann baust du dir eigentlich so ein zweistufiges System. Das heißt, du willst einmal im während der Datenstrom quasi vorbeifließt, willst du schon mal,
Natürlich den ganzen Mist weghaben,
machst du eine Art Vorkategorisierungen nach einem sinnvollen System, das dir nachher wieder hilft Sachen zu finden. Das heißt, du machst irgendwie nimmst was weiß ich, einfach mal die,
den Kommunikationspartner, als oder die äh oder ähnliche Sachen, sodass du halt in der Lage bist, einerseits in einem sehr schnellen Speicher,
Nach üblichen Suchen schnell zu finden, welche Datensätze bestimmte Suchbedingungen erfüllen,
und von dort links du dann auf den typischerweise langsameren Speicher, wo dann von mir aus nochmal die Vollkommunikation ist. Also sowas wie.
Ist Kommunikation von Tim? Ist E-Mail Kommunikation?
In Deutschland oder so, ja? Und das heißt, das, wonach du suchst, danach wird optimiert in dem schnellen Speicher und den Rest, den kannst du dir dann halt von irgendwelchen SSDs holen, wenn du dann die Vollkommunikation haben willst oder so. Ähnliche
ähnliche Sachen. Also da da spricht man quasi davon, ein Datenbankindex,
vierte immer darauf optimiert, wie du darin nachher wieder suchst. Also eine Datenbank musst du so bauen, dass sie,
Dass du vorher weißt, was du sie fragen wirst. Okay, aber das war jetzt nur so der technische Hintergrund. Ja, also,
Man sieht hier also was, da dazu zu sagen ist eigentlich nur ja, alle Unternehmen.
Sehen diesen Markt, der Überwachung als als Chance. Und wollen daran natürlich teilhaben.
Und ob das jetzt SAP ihre Hahner Datenbank an dem BND verkauft oder an die an die NSA am liebsten verkaufen sie wahrscheinlich einfach an alle. Ja, also es ist halt immer so.
Wollen Gewinn machen und derjenige, der diese derjenige, der diese Entscheidung dann irgendwie aus ethischen Erwägungen nicht trifft, müsste erklären.
Warum er diese Gelegenheit ausgelassen hat, dem Unternehmen Geld zu verdienen? Und.
Es ist offensichtlich dem Herrn McDonald einfacher gefallen.
Zu erklären, wie er dem Unternehmen Geld verdient und dann irgendwie eine ähm Pressemitteilung herauszugeben, die nicht zu den eigentlichen, die keinen Bezug zu den eigentlichen Vorwürfen hat.
Gut, wir verfolgen, wir verfolgen das. Haben wir's?
Ich denke ja, wir könnten noch ein paar Empfehlungen aussprechen.
Es geht los mit einer Empfehlung für unsere Freunde in Österreich, denn dort gibt es keinen Grund zu feiern. Am neunten April zweitausendfünfzehn ab neunzehn Uhr im Depot. Breite Gasse drei,
Wien,
der AK Vorrat Österreich möchte dort Erfolge der Vergangenheit feiern und Vorhaben für die nächsten Monate vorstellen. Generalsekretär von Amnesty International Österreich, Heinz Patzelt wird die Keynote halten.
Und in äh Berlin einen Hinweis in eigener Sache vom ersten bis zum dritten Mai zwanzig fünfzehn wird es den fünften Podlauf Podcaster Workshop geben. Nicht ganz nett politisch, orientiert, aber äh auch nicht ganz irrelevant, weil ihr wollt ja auch alle Podcasts machen. Da gibt's dann vor allem auch am ersten
Tag nochmal einen speziellen Developer Day, da folgt ihr einfach mal äh den Link in den Shownotes, da wisst ihr dann mehr dazu.
In direkter Folge auf den Podcast der Workshop hat sich strategisch der alljährliche Weltkongress der Social Media Berater positioniert.
Dieser findet statt vom fünften bis siebten Mai zweitausendfünfzehn in der Station Berlin.
Und wer nicht genug bekommen kann von tollen Ereignissen, der nimmt sich schon mal Urlaub und zwar vom dreizehnten bis zum siebzehnten August zwanzig fünfzehn, denn da steht das nächste Chaos Communication Camp an, auch das Fünfte im Übrigen,
ganz toll im Ziegeleipark Mildenberg anderthalb Stunde von Berlin entfernt und äh wir waren jetzt gerade auf dem Acker und durften feststellen
toller Ort, tolles Gelände und das wird äh bestimmt eine tolle Party und wir hätten euch natürlich gerne alle dabei. Ja, Linus,
Das war's eigentlich erstmal wieder für diese Woche, ne?
Ja, wie immer gilt der Dank den Hörern und Hörerinnen dieses Mal besonders hervorzuheben. Christian und eine unbekannte Person.
Ja genau, das machen wir gerne,
Ja und hier äh hattet hoffentlich mal wieder Spaß hier äh mit der Sendung. Wir bedanken uns natürlich auch für alle sonstigen Spender, Unterstützer, Tippgeber und äh auch Kommentarschreiber und finde, das läuft ganz gut so mit dem Feedback, also,
mal wieder was aufgefallen ist, was ihr unbedingt mal unbedingt klarstellen muss, weil jemand falsch war im Podcast, dann schreibt.
Also ich habe das gerade so so ironisch gesagt, dass er die Kommentare loswerden sollte. Ich kann nur nochmal betonen, dass wir,
dass ich keine Seite im Internet kenne mit einer besseren Kommentarkultur als Logbuch Netzpolitik. Muss ich echt sagen,
Oder filterst du die ganzen Spinner da so? Eisenhart raus. Nee, wir haben einfach gute Kommentare.
Ne, ich kann das generell für die gesamte Metaebene so bestätigen, also.
Nein, wir haben noch besser also im Meterebene Durchschnitt sind wir sogar noch gehoben.
Du liest alle meine Kommentare.
Nein, keinen einzigen. Die sind ja alle Quatsch, bis auf unsere.
Verstehe. Na gut. Okay, dann sagen wir tschüss. Das war's. Bis bald.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.